- We have to show, do we have this video?
''Cause I love this video
of your kids just losing it
when you went,
it made me cry.
- Yes Mommy!
Yes Mommy!
- Yes!
- They were, you guys, you guys,
- [Lisa] They were
screaming "Mommy, Mommy!"
- You guys
These
They were screaming "Mommy!"
(Lisa chuckles)
they were like going, I mean, it was like
it was literally the most beautiful thing.
I mean, as a momma of two, like,
I'm just like, there's nothing.
We do a lot of things, right?
And you love what you do and
you're proud of your moments,
but when your kids think
you're doing something cool,
when your kids are, "Oh my God."
I'm gonna cry again.
But, like when they, when
they, it just made me cry.
I was just like, sobbing,
watching it going
that is such a beautiful moment.
(crowd clapping)
Like, they see their mamma
like soaring, you know?
- [Sheryl] It was,
It was very,
being a mom and having
gone through a divorce
and making it up in my mind
that I had to raise happy, healthy people.
- Mhm.
When I saw my children cheer for me
in that moment, and I could
hear them from the stage,
I was like,
- Mommy! Yes Mommy!
I could,
I believed in my mind
I said, I did it.
Thank you, God.
Thank you mom and dad for the support.
Thank you. I did it.
- [Kelly] It was, I'm
gonna cry again, it's fine.
(Crowd clapping and cheering)
- [Lisa] You know, I
tell her all the time,
because again, I, the four kids
and also went through the divorce,
we share a lot of things in common
in terms of struggles after
a divorce, like many women.
And I tell her all the time
when I watch those kids
and how they are with her,
I'll just sit there in awe
and say, Your children with you are so,
they're so proud.
They are such good people.
- [Kelly] Beautiful
- Thanks.
- [Lisa] She has raised amazing people
and I'm very proud of my kids,
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- But I just hope that the
twins one day, like, recognize
I'm like, you know, I'm on TV? Like.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- They do!
- [Lisa ] I got a show on.
- [Kelly] They're just, like
that's great for you, mom.
- The older two, yeah, but
(laughter)
- But like, "I'm on Discord".
- Yeah!
(crowd laughs)
(Kelly laughs and claps)
- [Lisa] They don't care, and I'm like,
America loves this show, by the way.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But her kids always, always
supportive and beautiful.
- [Sheryl] They better,
you know what I went through to have them?
(laughter)
You better support me.